but let's talk about the news here we go
this is where it gets really weird from
popvortex.com you can see itunes top 10
music charts usa
top songs
let's go brandon featuring tyson james
and chandler crump bryson gray
let's go brandon extended version loza
alexander three let's go brandon loza
alexander knocking adele out of the
first place position then you get uh a
walker hayes you get ed sheeran then you
get elton john and the number eight is
let's go brandon wow wow but here's
crazy check this out check this out so
someone chatted actually when we were
starting the show that they removed it
and i'm like no no that would be too
obvious so i pulled up music.apple.com
us top 100 usa
and it's not there that's interesting
but this this is a different chart so i
don't i don't know exactly what's going
on because this is not the same chart
this is the most played songs in the us
updated every day and this is from
apple.com but they're different songs
so i don't know like adele is there easy
on me but then they have drake yeah and
drake isn't up here so maybe i don't
know what
i don't know am i missing something here
that's why i didn't title it that's why
i didn't that's why we need casey kasem
yeah yeah exactly tell us what's going
on do you guys remember casey yes i do
no who's that where am i myself casey
kasem he did like the top 40 40 yeah
oh my god that was great he would he had
this great voice and i think he lived to
be about 175 years old pretty much yeah
yeah yeah do it like that's the you know
it's like a lich like an undead yeah
yeah yeah yeah kind of like the dorito
commercial if you if you heard the voice
you might know it i bet you'd do a good
impression of it too probably up i guess
here's what's funny about this right so
where's the story here we go this is
from showbiz411 adele booming at radio
but temporarily knocked off itunes top
spot by moronic anti-biden's song nice
headline okay
this hold on hold on from october 25th
right okay here's what he says
easy on me was knocked off its perch at
number one on itunes after ten straight
days the temporary displacer is a
moronic single called let's go brandon
by bryson gray tyson and ante anti-biden
record for anti-vaxxers idiots
idiots are pushing this piece of crap up
the itunes chart but no one in their
right mind would spend money on it it's
not a song or a record it's just garbage
adele will be back at number one
tomorrow i love the framing maybe that's
why it's not on the maybe that's why
maybe people aren't buying it they're
just listening to it oh i don't know
maybe but but it is in the top list i
mean you saw it on your phone you
checked yeah let's go brendan's there
and then but this guy said october 25th
it would be knocked off the chart adele
will be number one
sorry dude did a fact check out also i
love that right this is the answer
on it yeah it's like the anti-biden song
is moronic and what like adele makes
music for
intellectuals yeah i don't know about
that maybe i like it i think she's i
don't i don't have anything against her
but is that just like more sophisticated
it's all pop music right pretty much
hello yeah yeah it's me
it's a great song let's go brandon is
you know the one hit wonder of of uh
2021 yeah yeah but it's two different
songs
it's there's there's two versions of it
well there's more than two versions
there's two different songs and then
multiple versions of one song remixes
and stuff yeah so i
people like let's go brandon yeah they
they really really like it and one thing
that i enjoy and look we all do this
we're all guilty of it but people who
don't produce anything trashing on
something that everybody else loves
right it's like this this song got into
the top charts three times literally
three times the exact same song because
it's moronic it's terrible no no no now
help me out with this guys um when
remember the song f donald trump yeah no
f donald trump that's it
real bop tim yeah that came out in 2016.
it actually reached number one on itunes
november 7 2020. oh nice yeah so f it's
called fdt is the name of the song but
can i say something oh sorry well is it
isn't let's go brandon a more creative
way of saying it than just like friends
this guy yeah like just saying f this
guy that's moronic that's why i think
let's go brandon does does really well
but what i was going to say is were
conservatives outraged over f donald
trump i think i think i remember some
people being like how cruel like it
knocked adele off
but that's because conservatives are
always saying that pop music is
everything that's true yeah yeah like
what remember when benjamin yeah they're
right
that was hysterical and also that song
is kind of yeah it's very nasty it's a
gross song it's not it's not a sexy song
there's no like there's no uh
intrigue when when ben shapiro
read the lyrics to whap oh my god and
then and then someone took it and put it
over what of course that was legit
hilarious true comedy so i kind of feel
like that's the big difference between
like if you're in the culture you're not
in the cult you know i like adele i
think that's really good
very talented yeah and um ed sheeran i
don't know a whole lot about him but i
got him and i got this really boring i
like elton john alan john's got a lot of
great classes me too yeah yeah goodbye
yellow brick road excellent music rocket
man come on who doesn't like that is
good yeah it doesn't like i prefer
william shatner's cover but
also good but so look i forgot about
that one it's so good rocket man
no but this is what's funny like even if
conservatives were criticizing the f
donald trump song they weren't going
they knocked it down
exactly exactly you know what's
interesting about that too is like so
the uh
the thing where low art became high art
in american culture
is what allowed adele to be think
something like critically acclaimed and
now they don't like that there's more
low art
already low art out also part of the
thing with let's go brandon is if the
song was
you know fdt but fjb right instead um
that would get censored all over the
place oh yeah that would be like hate
speech it would be racist to call the
old white male president
right names or something like somehow
that would all be wrong so this is a
nice little workaround of censorship as
well which we obviously need a great
deal of these i think i think bryson's
version is family friendly i haven't
heard it like he doesn't cuss or
anything good for him because he was
saying that youtube deletes like the
kids version like they're all popping
into this in the car with their family i
love it yep they say fudge yeah you know
and ship i just released biden bops if
anyone wants to check them
[Laughter]
mentioned this because youtube deleted
his video from youtube from youtube
saying that it was like medical
misinformation and he's like what wait
what was medical the song let's go
brandon yes like people are listening to
this song for medical advice
they're like well i was gonna get
vaccinated but then i heard let's go
brandon right that does not follow no
it's it's it's it's it's very obvious
the left controls cultural institutions
by force
they wouldn't if they didn't own these
platforms
they would not survive exactly this
music this you know it's really funny
when um we did a segment the other day
talking about bands like rage against
the machine in the offspring and i go
back and i look at some of this music i
i was looking at i think gone away by
the offspring reached the billboard hot
100 number one it was like a number one
single it is a really good song but then
you look at the video for it and it's
like it doesn't get a lot of play but
then you look at some other pop music
with billions of views and i'm like it
seems to me that back in the day
they were artificially propping up songs
that people didn't really care for yeah
that's how the industry worked and now
that people have the ability to choose
you can see what kind of music people
really do like well that's what happened
is record companies would send out the
songs to the radio stations and the
radio stations would have to play those
songs a certain number of times a day
interesting they would push them yeah
yeah i didn't realize that yeah they
would have like manufactured was the
old-time influencer model of radio
interesting so it's like it's crazy to
think about that a lot of the songs we
heard in the 90s was just a record label
being like we want to sell this song
it's like do people like there were some
bangers though you know
closing time yeah
glycerin yeah also good or glycerine i
don't know
green day
the whole were they were they really the
best or was it just that's all you could
get no i hated green day yeah green
definitely wow well that's a little
messed up not the best
[Laughter]
green is the worst i agree
yeah and they had their they got a they
got a broadway show i think green really
what didn't they yeah there was like a
musical there was a green day musical
that grosses me out i don't like that
huh i wonder it's really funny because
we talked about before too with um
american idiot
i remember i could be wrong about this
but my understanding was that they had
produced some garbage pop album with
like acoustic songs and then people
arragged at them for like not being punk
so then they scrapped the album and then
made american idiot and they were like
there's an original broadway cast
recording
of what correct american idiot oh of
course right it's political because it
was a uh that was a
musical tim the look of genuine
confusion on your face
why would they allow that in 2009 it uh
premiered at berkeley rep oh it won a
grammy gross and weird don't like that
wow yeah
record company grammys i hate all that
stuff yeah literally just patting
themselves on the back anytime the
industry gives itself an award it's also
an opportunity so that you could get up
on stage and tell everybody how proud
you are to have had an abortion yep
right yep murdered my child good and
you're all horrible people at home maybe
not quite i don't know i was saying
grammys who did that oh that was oscars
that was awesome
i'm sorry i get confused with the
celebrities awarding themselves yeah
exactly
doing a little bit of this patting
themselves in the back they're all doing
it all the time
which reminds me we're going to be doing
the official tim cast award exactly oh
who's going to win oh we're going to win
i want you to famous oh oh
what do you win what's my award
beautiful you're going to be at golden
alpaca well i'd like to thank my
abortion doctor
is men should get up there on the stage
and they should talk about how they
encourage their girlfriends to have
abortions or their wives to have
abortions so that their careers could be
that much better without having the
burden of children and then
these these not fathers could be
applauded for having uh
exterminated pregnancies this is the
exact why do we only celebrate women who
kill their children opportunity you know
what i mean single argument i saw when
people were hashtagged shouting their
abortions every argument i saw equally
applied to deadbeat dads
yeah every single one was like well it
helped me get further along in my career
i wasn't ready for a childhood you could
say this about a guy who just abandons
his kids those are crazy arguments too
yeah like i wanted to have a career and
go to school and it's like you can do
that like someone had to die like a
person
it's so emotionally manipulative here's
what they'll do you'll show a woman a
mammogram of what her actual child or
not a man
i'm getting confused because planned
parenthood
planned parenthood claims they have
mammograms but they don't um so that's
always in my head when i discuss the
points they literally have no mammograms
no not at all
they have
for sure but i'm sorry mammograms so if
you show someone an ultrasound of what
their child actually looks like that's
emotional manipulation but if you
convince women that they'll just never
achieve their dreams unless they kill
their baby that's reasonable yeah that's
fine yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you